people wish upon a star because they
have some intuition that aiming above
the mundane has the potential to
transform themselves they make a wish
well if you're going to make a wish you
should aim at something high and even
just aiming at that is more likely to
make the wish come true and this is not
metaphor you know I have this program
which you guys are going to do called
the future authoring program it's one of
two assignments one is that you write an
autobiography that's the past authoring
the other is that you write a plan for
the future that's the future authoring I
would recommend that you get started on
those right now like not right now but
like really soon because they're harder
than you think and some of you are going
to write like 15,000 words you're going
to get sucked right in this happens all
the time you're going to get sucked
right into it and so you write an
autobiography because you need to know
where you are and who you are right now
because how the hell are you going to
plot a pathway to the future unless you
know where you are and then you need to
write about the future because you're
not going to hit something unless you
aim at it that's for sure
and lots of times people won't aim at
what they want because they're afraid
the reason they're afraid is because if
you specify what you want you specified
your conditions of failure you know when
you fail and it's better just to keep it
foggy it's like well I don't know if I'm
succeeding or failing but you know I
can't really tell well great except you
can't hit anything you don't aim at and
so the future authoring problem program
is like it's an attempt to have you
articulate your character and so it's
the past authoring program who are you
and you know the past authoring program
allows you to break your life into
epochs and then to write about the
emotional you know the things that you
regard as important important events
that have shaped who you are and you
know you may find that some of those
some of that writing makes you emotional
I would say if you have a memory that's
more than 18 months old roughly speaking
and when you bring it to mind it has an
emotional impact
see a negative emotional impact there
it's like part of your soul is stuck
back there
and I know that's a metaphorical way of
thinking about it but what I mean is
that the reason that you still
experience the emotion is because you
have not solved the problem that that
situation faced you with it might be a
real problem like maybe you got tangled
up with someone who is really bad and
that's rough man because you've got to
come up with a theory of malevolence to
deal with something like that and that's
no joke
but if it still produces emotion it
means you haven't solved the problem and
we and your your brain is still tagging
it as threat it's a part of your
territory that you did not master threat
threat threat threat threat and until
you take it apart and articulation
really helps out writing really helps
out then you're not going to free
yourself from its grip and that what
might not be that Pleasant I mean this
is one of those situations where doing
it tends to produce a decrement in
people's mode in the short term but
quite radical improvements three to six
months down the road you know and it's
often the case that you unfortunately
have to do something you don't want to
do in order to progress very very common
so and the future authoring program asks
you about different dimensions of your
life like because you're you know you
can take yourself as a personality
inside your head but you're nested in
systems that transcend you and they're
just as real as whatever's in your head
it's like well what do you need for life
well that's pretty easy actually some
friends that's a good thing
intimate relationship that's a good
thing a family you know either the one
you're going to produce or the one that
you come from where people to some
degree love and care for one another
that's a good thing to work on you need
you need some plan for your career
you've got to fit in somewhere that
people regard as important and they'll
trade with you so that you can live you
need something worthwhile to do with the
time that you're not at work and you
need to pay attention to your mental and
physical health and you need to regulate
your use of
substances which is a strange one but
alcohol does lots of people in so it's
worth it's worth thinking about that's
why we put it in there so then it's like
okay what the hell you want what do you
want from your friends what do you want
from your family what do you want from
your career you could have what you
wanted that's what the program asks you
three to five years down the road you
get to have what you want now I'm
assuming that you're going to approach
this like you know reasonable adults and
not like thirteen-year-old dreamers I
think I want the most expensive yacht in
the world it's like fine but you know
that isn't really what it's supposed to
be more concentrating on your character
and so then it asks you to write for 15
minutes without thinking too much about
grammar or sentence structure any of
that about what your life could be like
three to five years down the road if you
were treating yourself like someone you
cared for and you were helping them
figure out what they wanted and then it
asks you to do the same thing in Reverse
which is to think about the ways that
you're radically insufficient and your
fault and everyone knows this I think
you know maybe not but everyone has a
sense of if they were going to
degenerate how they would do it you know
some people would be an alcoholic some
people would be a street person it's
like there's some doom staying out there
that's got your name on it if you're
particularly in cautious and you know
don't and let things fall apart so won't
you'd write about that what do you not
want to have happen in three to five
years and the psychological reasons for
this a one is if you have some the aim
for that's a source of positive emotion
because your positive emotion is mostly
generated by evidence that you're moving
towards something that you value it's
not generated so much by accomplishing
something because when you accomplish
something you're just left with the
problem of whatever you're going to do
next so you graduate from university
it's like you know hooray one day you're
at the peak of your undergraduate
university career the next day you're
unemployed and looking for a bad job at
our box so you know well you see what I
mean is you know it's it's that you know
one problem that you solve is replaced
by another problem and so the idea that
you're going to be happy when you solve
all your problems is like ah good luck
with that theory but but you know if
you're aiming at something worthwhile
and you really believe it's worthwhile
and you've thought it through you know
so that you're not weak you're not weak
you've got your damn arguments mustered
then when you make progress even a
little bit you think hey that's all
right and you get a little kick
you know dopamine kick and that's what
you want is that's where your positive
emotion comes from you can use cocaine
if you want but but you know that tends
to have relatively detrimental medium to
long term consequences but it activates
the same system so you have to be aiming
at something and you should be aiming at
something that's realistic that you want
that you could get you know like not
easily because if it's easy in some
sense you've already got it it's going
to push you and that's part of the
pleasure actually because there's two
things that you want to do when you're
pursuing something that's important and
one of them is to get the thing that's
important but the other is is to make
yourself better at pursuing things right
so so you can get both of those at the
same time you you you're aiming out
something and you're increasing your
competence it's like that's a good deal
that's a good deal and there's a lot of
intrinsic meaning to be felt in that
then the second half of the program you
you write out a plan for for how you're
going to do it and how you're going to
keep yourself on track and you can write
about why it would be good for you if
you did this and why it would be good
for your family and what possible
benefits it would have to the community
you know because you want to nail this
thing down and then you want to figure
out what kind of obstacles are going to
come up and how you might overcome them
and how you might keep yourself on track
and all of that and we know because
we've actually done a lot of research on
this particular program that if
University students do this and this is
more true if they're not too well
oriented to begin with if university
students do this they're about 25% less
likely to drop out which is a lot and
about their grade point average
increases
about 20% so hooray for that you know
because you never know when you develop
an intervention if it's going to work
there's also evidence but not from my
lab that doing such things improves your
physical health and I think the reason
for that is is that you know when you go
over your autobiography and you scour
out those negative places that you're
sort of dragging along with you it
lowers your overall stress load because
your brain is kind of I think it's
calculating how dangerous the world is
by attending to the ratio of successes
to failures that you've had in your life
something like that and so you know if
there are holes in your map that you
could still fall through then your brain
regards the territory still has a bit on
the dangerous side and then you more
prepared for emergency action and that's
hard on you so you want to go back there
and fix up those experiences to the
degree that you can't